you know I said that was more interested
in the mystery than the dramatics show
would beg to differ broadchurch Episode
five don't mind the eyes I at time of
recording today I went to the Green
Mountain Comic Expo and I was flying my
Slytherin house colors in a number of
ways including a little bit of eye of
eye makeup so just roll with it I didn't
feel like dealing with it before shot
this so anyways broadchurch episode of
fine now episode 5 does something that
in general
I hate which is relationship overload I
don't know what it is about TV shows
that make them think you know this
episode we're gonna have this emphasis
on this relationship you know that's
been around for a while it's been a big
central for we're gonna have a big move
in there and then somebody in the room
goes oh and we should have all the other
relationship stuff happen in this
episode - my least favorite episode of
Game of Thrones was the bear and the
maiden fair from season 3 because they
everybody have their romantic stories
moving forward and I'm not I don't
always hate romantic plots leanings
inclinations of characters and I don't
always hate it just about 95% of the
time because 95% of the time I don't
think it's necessary I don't think it
moves the story forward I don't think
it's to the benefit of everything and I
think it's the most artificial way to
try and jack up the relationships the
tension the I don't even know what they
want then what they think is trying to
accomplish and this episode does it to
such a degree and so many times it's
actually kind of mind-blowing and
there's a decent chance I'm gonna for
get some of it so obviously we've got
the progression of what's going on with
Jodie Whittaker and her husband I'm too
frustrated to look up the yeah Beth and
Mark there we go I remembered their
names finally so Beth the mark so we've
got that which also ties into the the
woman that Mark had the affair with her
name I can't remember right now so you
you've got these three people involved
in that but we're also gonna touch on
the daughter and her boyfriend okay fine
we're gonna get a whole bunch of
backstory on jack which is actually
gonna touch on his love life not just
like in a skeevy way but and let's have
a romantic leimia and and dig into this
a bit more way okay fine
and then we're gonna have Miller get hit
on by one of her co-workers for no
reason that I can figure out and then
have David Tennant's character hit on
the woman that Mark had the effect why
what what is all that why is this here I
don't care like there is an off chance
that maybe two out of these actually
contribute to the story and matter but
why are they piled up on top of each
other like this this is just stupid and
annoying as hell I really really didn't
like this episode and the only thing
that I can say that I hope is that I
hope that this is what in many ways the
bear in the main affair in Game of
Thrones was which was as much I hated
that episode the fact that they loaded
all the heavy romantic stuff into that
wine episode basically meant they were
done with it it was like ripping off a
band-aid and there was a lot less of it
across the rest of the season after that
so that's my hope my hope is is that
they poured oh and the reporter guy
kissing it now he's with the woman who's
from the out-of-town report so it is my
desperate hope that they loaded it all
up into this one so that we can move on
from it and be done and not have
much of it anymore I don't know how
hopeful I am for that but that's my only
hope
cuz oh my god so little move forward in
terms of the mystery in terms of the
thing that hooked me and initially and
as irritated as I am with this episode
there are some things that work most of
the stuff with Jack works and is
actually pretty well balanced I really
like the scene with Mark going to see
him and talk to him as there's like a
crowd praying for the man's blood you
know just outside this building and Mark
is talking to him and I get I I can
sense it or at least this was my read on
it that Mark is really hoping that
whatever Jack says it makes things
perfectly easy and black and white and
simple for it but the story that jack
tells I'm not gonna say makes him a
wholly sympathetic character cuz it's
still like a little in but it muddies
the waters enough that you definitely
see that mark did not get you know the
clean oh I can just say this guy's a bad
guy think that part of him was probably
hoping for and I think that that played
really well it was probably a good idea
to have Jack be removed from the story
by the end of this episode because as it
was going along I'm like you know
there's a decent chance that this whole
thing is gonna turn into a story about
vigilante justice and now that he's dead
it won't it can't so that's good but
that so that seemed worked very well
that was a highlight trying to think
there was there was something else and
I'm kind of I'm I'm really starting to
wonder what the heck is going on with
this house cleaner the one who lives in
the caravan park the one with the dog
cuz like everything seems wrong about
her I don't know what yet not entirely
sure what's going on there
and oh the you know what the other thing
that was really good was was Beth and
Mark going through old pictures of Danny
and smiling and laughing and for one
night setting all the crap aside and
just remembering how good things could
be it felt like a realistic coping
mechanism for the two of them to have
particularly at that particular point at
the time that it happens and and that
and that worked pretty well also uh I'm
a little bit frustrated that Beth went
and took out most of her frustration on
the woman I mean that's not to say she'd
let mark off the hook she didn't
but like when she tells him that she's
pregnant
and he's his his first response is you
have to keep it oh I wanted to reach
through the TV and hit him it's like oh
shut up you have no business saying
anything in this moment I'm not gonna
say you have no business saying anything
ever but in this moment right now shut
up oh boy
um and and I think I I think they played
Beth's
frustration with that really well I'm
again I'm a little frustrated she
redirected it at the woman but again
that's not untrue to life so I as while
I don't care for that because it's the
more played out expected way to see it
go you know stay away from my man and
all that I it is kind of what happens at
least a good chunk if not the majority
of the time so yeah that's fine and it
didn't linger on that too much I don't
think but you know so that there are a
few interesting things the investigation
really really felt like it slowed to a
crawl in this one like the whole episode
just feels weird Lee tangental I I feel
like narrative Lee I'm gonna look back
I get this episode and go the only
purpose of this episode was to remove
Jack from the story and and show that
yes if you thought it was him that was a
red herring he's dead it wasn't him at
least I presume I suppose it's possible
could turn out to be him but that'd be
weak so like as far as the narrative
move moving forward that feels like the
only thing of a note that happened
Jack's dead now he's no longer in the
story so he's no longer a suspect and
just doing that is something that could
have been done in an episode that
actually moved other things forward
moved the investigation forward I mean
what did we find out about cigarette
butts yay
and you know I'm starting to get
frustrated with you know Miller's kid
and and her husband the kid's dad cuz
you know there's kids out there asking
you know how long would you know someone
who killed Danny go to jail oh did they
find anything on his phone and like he's
not nothing's pinging his radar like
it's kind of an odd question like I
understand like you don't want to pry
because you know your kids dealing with
the fact that his friends dead so you
know you figure I'll let him cope
however he's gonna cope but it doesn't
ping your radar that these are weird
questions this kid like he keeps asking
you over and over what is what his mom
found out what do they know like that
the fact that he hasn't mentioned that
to to his wife yet is starting to bug me
I'm we got the introducing introducing
what introduction of her sister who's
apparently a mooch who may or may not
know anything be curious to see how that
plays out I hope it plays out in some
way cuz otherwise what was the point I'm
gonna assume it does so I mean I'm not
I'm not writing off the show because you
know they like I said I'm hoping that
this was everything was crammed into it
episode so there will be less of it
later on we'll see I don't know if this
can this can very easily bounce back in
later episodes just reefa I've said in I
think every episode prior to this one
that it's done a good balancing act
between the family and town and
character drama and the mystery and this
episode does not balance at all the
mystery is like just hang it's this limp
thing just hanging off this big ball of
stupid drama that I don't care about so
with not a fan of this episode at all
really hoping the show bounces back from
it with the next one but broadchurch
episode 5 what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like and subscribe but follow
me on Twitter some more main patreon and
cetera etc etc links for all that stuff
and more is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]